that Disney enough for you let us guess
[Music]
walkabout to Kalama with me Josh sings
in haste and today in a special edition
of Ready Steady beauty by Drew Barrymore
do you are gonna give me a do-over ever
I will focus on some skin okay fabulous
for some hydration and elimination
keeping it even and then a lip oh great
well let's get lip a let's go okay this
is my favorite product like in our
entire lines called supernova a
celestial skin elixir and it has just
basically changed my life I'm going Pat
McGrath okay oh love it lots of pattern
if you were gonna pitch this range in
kind of like a telly shopping fashion
mm-hmm how would you pitch it the top
line formulas first okay that's what
we're about with flower deliver close
the prestige formulas at mass prices
you're a good saleswoman at the end of
the day thank you right now an
advertising because it's storytelling
what story are we telling today with
this leg what's my story gonna be
hydrated dewy youthful or just quenched
skin that was by the way our concealer
wand which is phenomenal
and made by a prestige lab I think I
need to move into becoming a contour
junkie but as I get older and my nose
widens out and my chin doubled up but
you know what I'm in no rush
we're not keeping up with the Kardashian
contouring just yet no but I do think
you know I think those girls really do
know what's going on oh and they have
had impressive longevity yes with the
contouring especially with everything
like they're just kind of doing it and
you know owning it if I want to be a bit
more jure Barrymore in everyday life
what vikon turns Manchus would you give
to me don't ever be mean
it's not its life is too short just be
kind to everyone you're kind of like
walking talking Disney character life is
like a just you have to go through a lot
of Shi T to get to that oh I'm so sorry
blowing oh my god so sorry that was such
a faux pas 999 gallons down by any
consolation I'm just poked in the eye
all the time when it comes to beauty
what's been your biggest beauty regret
when you look back you're like hon I
should not try it that I don't have any
I have fashion regrets I just want to
see your fashion moments where I'm like
oh Jesus God high waist with that high
neck way to make your boobs look like
two giant bananas you want my crown not
like ski slopes of these which would you
pick I mean spoilt for choice
a let's go this I'm feeling like
basically a violet vixen what are your
top tips are being in lesion your inner
vixen would you say at 43 with two kids
I don't know very well but I always say
put on music yeah a pair of high heels
and a bold lip oh my god that changes
everything what was going on I'm trying
to do lip liner while you're talking at
80 or get the challenge you're really
nice shaped lips
oh stop you stop talking how we looking
good I'm just trying to patch up my
little yellow mistake will ya Oh
[Music]
how do i potty like trade just run up to
the bar have a shot of tequila hang out
with your friends enjoy your time and
then go home and throw yourself into bed
and start all over dad day and try and
make some memories because memories are
the things we take with us what's this
project we're using right now oh this is
um our lift and sculpt and I used the
shimmer and shine Wow no I got cardi
Jenna like Instagram filter oh do the
trick I was that your yeah this is
something got very untidy well take it
or leave it cuz it helped oh babe you've
been a delight thank you so much I now
got my driver I think you need a drink
now I think I need a drink of the pub
where we're going right let's go hello
[Laughter]
[Music]